بعد عام ونصف من التحقيق تخللها اكثر من
1000 شهاده تصل اللجنه المؤلفه من سته
ديمقراطيين وجمهوريين الى تسليم نتائجها
للتصويت عليها الاثنين
اللجنه التي تعرف باسم السادس من يناير
ستقدم لوائح التهام ضد الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب حيث تصف ما فعله الرئيس
بمحاوله انقلابيه وستظهر حجم الترهيب
والضغط الذي يتهم الترام بممارسته على
مسؤولي الانتخابات في ولايه جورجيا
وارزونا رغم شهاده ابنتي ومستشاريه الذين
لم يصدقوا ان الانتخابات كانت مزوره
[موسيقى]
اذا لم يكن هذا عمل اجرامي فلا اعرف ماذا
نسميه
بعض المصادر ذاكره ان التهم التي ستوجه
لترامب هي الدعوه للتمرد عرقله السير
عمليه المصادقه على نتائج الانتخابات
التامر على الدوله
اللجنه حاولت اثبات ان رفض ترامب لنتائج
الانتخابات لم يكن رد فعل على الهزيمه بل
كان ضمن استراتيجيه مدروسه للبقاء في
السلطه وقلبي نظام الحكم
وسيتم نشر نتائج التحقيق كامله الاربعاء
وستدفع الى وزاره العدل التي عينه
وستقدم اللجنه توصيات تشريعيه لعدم تكرار
ما حدث في السادس من يناير ناديا البلبيسي
العربي واشنطن